how many people here would like to be in
better physical health raise your hands
let me see raise them high don't be
scared summer you're scared get it
higher baby let me tell you how to do
that i'm going to help you right now i
would like you to eat healthier less
calories and cleaner
and i would like you to go to the gym
and do physical exercise but what do
people want
they want to take some [ __ ] apple
vinegar gummy pills if they've got paper
they want
surgery same with business
this [ __ ] is simple do the right things
the right things will happen but people
are always looking for [ __ ] shortcuts
people are looking to point [ __ ]
fingers instead of thumbs that's how our
society is anxious gratitude will make
you happy every day and make your
business better you know why because as
we sit here right this second there are
850 million people on earth that do not
have access to clean water this is a
mindset game
this is a perspective game you want to
find positivity i do it for a living
guess what it's there 24 7. you want to
be happy it's unlimited you choose
what life is
that's how i think about business
anything you do that is not nice
is costing you money and the faster you
figure that actually out
and the faster you figure out why you're
not nice the more likely you'll be
successful um i'm really happy to be
here uh
i'm really looking forward to the
fireside chat because i really want it
to be contextual to the industry
obviously given that my sister's in it i
i've always paid a lot of attention to
it because i always feel that there's so
much ambition and
entrepreneurial tendencies in the real
estate industry but i also i've always
been fascinated by it because it's
similar to the reason i like the nft
market and why i always loved
collectibles because i'm fascinated by
the concept of markets going up and down
especially if you break down my content
i think so much of it speaks to being
practical and being self-aware and
staying in your lane and people
really get caught in this industry by
being over excited when times are good
and not anticipating when times are bad
and so it's been really interesting to
watch over the last 30 years
the way to win
how easy it is to lose
and so many variables in it the thing
that i probably want to talk most about
is
what i've been spending a lot of my time
on lately which is
what does it take from an emotional
intelligence standpoint to actually be
successful i think the concept of soft
skills
has been really fascinating to me that
when we talk about empathy or kindness
or patience
we consider them soft skills
and
i truly believe that they're the actual
hard skills of business
that knowing how to write up a contract
or use excel
or like run the math
is actually quite easy
what i think is very hard is when
another human being is incredibly
disrespectful to your face and having
the intestinal fortitude to be the
bigger person in that moment for what
you're trying to accomplish
and i think it's time
that we really start having this
conversation in the business world that
how many people here have employees
raise your hand
raise it high
thank you so for example for all the
people that just raised their hand
something i've been thinking a lot about
lately is the concept of does anybody
here actually have the explanation to
why it is ever appropriate for a boss
to scream and yell at somebody in a
negative way in front of other people
like like
yeah we're all like no no no never
but
it happens every [ __ ] day
it and i've been fascinated by because
i'm like
wow like
for a long time the context of doing
business
has been used as an excuse
framework
for just
bad behavior and comma and here's the
most interesting part
i'm stunned by how many people are
confused that fear
is a better motivator than love
i'm fascinated by that
you know
the hypothesis of my new book and how i
wrote it and really what i think about
and really covid gave me the opportunity
to really finally put on paper what's
been on the tip of my tongue what's
always been in my stomach what's been
back here but i got it out there is
i'm trying to build the biggest empire
in the world i want to be the single
most successful entrepreneur of all time
financially
like the points the money i have no
concern about saying that but i'm
stunned by
the fact that people feel that you have
to compromise your values to be
successful
i'm i remember
when steve jobs got wildly popular in
silicon valley
and i would be at conferences and i
would talk about how i was so marveled
by his incredible innovation skills but
i didn't love the way the narrative was
being painted about how he treated
employees and it was like i was watching
kids young kids who are starting apps
and companies genuinely
almost think it was cool to be tough on
their people
not that they were so bad but they
thought like this was going to motivate
them and i was very affected by it
and i think that it's really led to a
place where for me as my profile and the
attention on me has grown
that i feel incredibly compelled
to have the conversation of my
management style it's why i had to go
vulnerable which is not my favorite move
with this book because in 12 and a half
i talk about
my half being candor gary v on stage and
in content is a beast when it comes to
candor it's my strength gary vaynerchuk
as an operator
was really bad at it i actually just
genuinely didn't like the feeling of
delivering bad news telling someone they
weren't good at what they did
i didn't value money enough so i'd be
willing to keep people around i tried a
hundred different ways to fix it without
telling them that they stink
and then what would ultimately happen is
i would get resentment i would hold on
for dear life for three years and then
finally on a random tuesday surprise the
[ __ ] out of them and fire them
which
is the complete scenario of why anybody
who's ever worked for me does not like
me in a world where that shouldn't be
the case based on who i am and how i
value money
and i had to go through that in my late
30s and early 40s even probably early
40s and recently
and what has transpired once i kind of
tricked myself i almost garyvee'd myself
and basically put the word kind in front
of candor and i've managed that way for
the last two years and for anybody and i
saw a lot of you with your body language
who have that
shortcoming
it has been staggering how effective
kind candor has been for me and has been
foundational
in the growth of vayner x and vayner
media over the last 24 months
other people candor comes very natural
the problem is they deliver it like a
dick face
and that's never gonna work you know
genuinely making someone not feel good
genuinely scaring someone is a losing
formula you can more
than easily use it in the short term to
capture some cash i promise you you will
leave money on the table deploying that
format
and
it's an important convo
because we have not in popular culture
had the conversation that warm and kind
and nice is the actual alpha skill to
make lots of money
and i'm [ __ ] here for it and i hope
you're ready for it
[Applause]
it's a big deal
because my book isn't like let's all go
to a mountain and drink tea and pray
nice [ __ ] will happen
this is not a [ __ ] delusional like
like it's all gonna be okay this is if
you want to dominate
long term
the reason so many people lose in the
real estate market overall they will in
nfts they doing collectibles and many
other things is they want money fast and
they do short term behavior and they
don't thoughtfully think long
term right they overextend themselves
game over
that's how i think about emotional
intelligence
if you play in a way where every
relationship appreciates you and do you
listen
do you understand what i'm talking about
when i talk about strength i'm actually
not i love this subject because i want
to get deeper into it
of course it's easy to be nice to
someone who's nice to you
i'm talking about the other [ __ ]
i'm not like everyone's like yeah i'm
nice i'm like but what about last
thursday when you wanted to punch patty
in the face well she was a [ __ ] i'm
like [ __ ] you
i'm like that's what i'm talking about
not when shit's easy when shit's hard
everybody in this room has likely had
someone get cute
and not pay you for some [ __ ]
what do you do then
how do you have the strength emotionally
to be the bigger person
do you waste your energy on envy and
jealousy or talking [ __ ] about that
person
or are you on the offense and just
moving on
this is money talk
this isn't grandma's nice talk this is
money talk
and that's the nuance that i'm trying to
bring to the forefront of the
conversation i
am going to make uncomfortable levels of
money on the foundation of kindness
when i dissect what's going on with me
and how it's happening it is grounded
in patience it is grounded in empathy it
is grounded
in compassion
it is grounded in that stuff
people like gary this is all wrong i'm
nice and people walk all over me i'm
like let's break it down becky
but tell me how you're nice
now let me tell you about the
conversations when i broke down the
people that tell me they get walked all
over and that's why it can't be nice
let me make it real simple for everybody
here's what's actually happening it's
one of two things
one
they're actually trying to manipulate
people
this whole conversation of i get walked
all over no no you tried to give
somebody some [ __ ] that they didn't even
want
because you wanted something from them
garyvee see you're coming to dallas let
me give you a ride to the hotel
to save you some money on the car
translation
hey dude i want to pitch you [ __ ] for 35
minutes while i get you to the hotel
that happens every day
people out here trying to act kind
they're using it as manipulation
like don't give me [ __ ] i don't want
and then ask immediately after
that's not kind that's manipulation
that's number one or number two
you're kind
but you're scared to negotiate you're
insecure
and it has nothing to do with you being
kind
you're getting walked all over
because you're unhappy that somebody's
negotiating
in business
you just genuinely wish you could get
more for it
you could have said no
we we lack accountability i just talked
the other day i'm like
but but i had to sell it for 40. i was
like but you said yes
you could have told harold to go [ __ ]
himself
you said yes
nobody walked all over you you folded
because it was a good deal for you
or you needed to move it
i'm fascinated by what's going on in the
world
we've gotten into such a funny place
for a million different reasons
and i just want people to lock in on
themselves and realize how much
opportunity you have
the biggest thing i'd like to leave with
before we go into this q a
is
there's never been more opportunity if
you're willing to a be accountable
that's my favorite
people mad
at like their brokerage is not doing
enough for them leave dick
where's the accountability you don't
like it
oh this this partner's always screwing
me up don't do business with him and her
just an utter lack of accountability
you're in control
nobody's making you do [ __ ] this is not
the ussr where my sister and my parents
are from you are in america
nobody's making you do [ __ ]
what you are is you're a cry baby
and you want you know it's really hard a
lot you know we are an empire america we
are in now 50 years of prosperity
people are soft
so they complain about dumb [ __ ]
stop doing that
right like
i get emails from og real estate people
all the time like
you know this is a [ __ ] you know my
business is down i'm like you're not
making tick tocks
you're not posting
you're not doing it
you still have [ __ ] bench ads
that's why you're losing
like
[ __ ] changes i'm pumped that you were
the queen of queensborough for five
years it's over
mike tyson used to be the champ of the
world
people are so entitled i used to
dominate berkeley town i'm like but you
don't anymore
because you [ __ ] on social that's where
people's attention is you're not making
content nobody knows what the [ __ ] it's
you have a nice reputation you're still
getting some referrals but you're not as
hungry anymore
people like act as if it's entitled to
them
if you don't work it's not going to
happen
period
and what's crazy about that is it's
simple
everybody how many people here would
like to be in better physical health
raise your hands
let me see raise them high don't be
scared some of your skin get it higher
baby let's get high
ready let me tell you how to do that i'm
going to help you right now
i would like you to eat healthier less
calories and cleaner
and i would like you to go to the gym
and do physical exercise
but what do people want
they want to take some [ __ ] apple
vinegar gummy pills
if they've got paper they want
surgery
same with business this [ __ ] is simple
do the right things the right things
will happen
but people are always looking for
[ __ ] shortcuts people are looking to
point [ __ ] fingers instead of thumbs
that's how our society is anxious
accountability will set you free
gratitude will set you we sit here right
now gratitude will make you happy every
day and make your business better you
know why because as we sit here right
this second there are 850 million people
on earth that do not have access to
clean water
and we're complaining about some dumb
[ __ ]
this is a mindset game
this is a perspective game
you want to find things that are bad
good news you can go on the internet and
take all your time with it just turn on
cable tv and the news they sell you
negativity 24 7.
you're more than welcome you want to
find positivity i do it for a living
guess what it's there 24 7. you want to
be happy it's unlimited
you choose what life is
that's how i think about business
anything you do that is not nice
is costing you money and the faster you
figure that actually out and the faster
you figure out why you're not nice
[Music]
the more likely you'll be successful
thank you
[Music]
you